hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
today's what i eat in a day review is
sponsored by bilpar
and we'll be looking at another harper's
bazaar food diaries video
from lana condor but before i get into
it
i want to chat about my sponsor buildbar
so if you're a regular abby's kitchen
fan here
you've been watching me work through
this box of build bars each week
now i'm not usually a fan of protein
bars because i think most of them
taste like chalk but these taste legit
like a chocolate bar
filled with a marshmallow they're so
good
so far i'd say my favorite flavor has
been cookies and cream
but today we're gonna try something new
let's take a look-see eeny meeny miny
moe
catch a tiger by the candy cane brownie
fun all right this one's got 17 grams of
protein
oh little candy cane bits on top
if you love that classic holiday
chocolate and
peppermint candy cane flavor you're
gonna love this so much
um like i said 17 grams of protein so
it's great if you're trying to
bump up the protein in a meal or in a
snack and if i was using this as a
post-workout snack
i would probably pair this with like a
piece of fruit or some toast
for muscle repair since it is a lower
sugar snack
and i know you guys were loving what i
said about the zero guilt message on the
label
and i'm going to revise that statement
to say that unless you've
stolen it from a baby or a very hungry
breastfeeding mama all foods should be
zero guilt anyways if you want to try
them out i'm going to leave a link below
for 20
off of your order also you can pause the
screen or look at the description to
check out my disclaimer
including a trigger warning for those
with current or previous experiences
with disordered eating
a reminder that this format follows a
celebrity's description of
what they eat and ultimately tells me
very little
about its accuracy portions brands
cooking preparation etc
not to mention their overall
relationship with food so
take this more as general education to
the masses
not so much as specific recommendations
to lana
and of course don't forget to subscribe
to this channel and ring that little
bell so that you never miss out on
a episode all right lovelies let's get
in there
so i eat a lot just
in general a huge amounts of food
i have always been this way ever since i
was little and i also am not
the type of person that can eat the same
thing every day
oh gosh i love her but also she's just
like
too pretty for words um i'm getting
sidetracked here by my little girl crush
gotta focus focus on the food
all right let's hear it green tea with
antioxidants
and i am a coffee drinker while i'm
working but if i'm not working
tea is the way to go i like i literally
can't even speak
unless i have my morning tea so you guys
know i never critique people's coffee or
tea orders um but i would say it
actually makes probably more sense to me
to go with the tea
on days that you're working if you're
looking to get like a little boost in
energy levels
without a crash midday at work
while green tea does have caffeine in it
it also contains a powerful antioxidant
called
l-theanine which research suggests may
help promote better
focus alertness attention and
sharpness which are all things that you
would probably want as a busy actress on
set
but again i'm not gonna mess with her
coffee or tea
routine and then it's breakfast time
breakfast time is my favorite time lunch
time is also my favorite time
and dinner time is my favorite time this
girl
is me now i'm like super pumped to see
what she's gonna eat
but it's scrambled eggs with a little
tiny bit of tomato sauce
um and then morning star
veggie breakfast links cut up and put
into the scramble
that does sound legit amazing to me
it kind of sounds slightly like
shikshuka but
with a higher egg to tomato sauce ratio
i guess
but regardless tomatoes and eggs are
bffs
so i think she's on to something and
then i'll
we'll typically do avocado with some
olive oil drizzled over
and a crack of salt and
everything but the bagel seasoning from
trader joe's which is my jam and i carry
it
in my purse when i'm working that's it
that's it this woman stole my identity
call the cops this is freaking me out
identity theft is not a joke okay so i
don't actually
carry the bagel seasoning in my purse
while working because
i don't leave the house and i don't
think i've packed a purse
in like a whole year hashtag coveted
life but if i
did leave the house and i did pack a
purse
i would put my everything but the bagel
seasoning
inside it for sure but anyways
this breakfast sounds like perfection
we've got
loads of protein in the eggs and the
veggie sausages
healthy fats in the avocado carbs in the
bread
and we've got some produce thrown in
there for good measure
nothing i would do differently here
canada i'm not much of a snacker
i'm more of an entreeer like why eat a
snack when you can eat
a full meal i mean that is a very good
point i guess the only answer to that
question is
that you're only hungry for a snack
but i am here for this girl's appetite
but if i do snack i'll snack on canned
sardines
or canned oysters the canned sardines
i'll just put
just a little extra crack of himalayan
salt on it i'll just eat it right out of
the tin
have like some wheat thins with the
oysters and i'll put like the oyster on
the wheat fins
and eat it okay so this is where we
diverge
in palette i'm just kidding girl i'm not
here to yuck your yum
canned fish is not my style but
super nutritious for you so it's
definitely a choice i support
so both the canned sardines and oysters
are packed with protein
iron and omega-3s actually sardines in
fact are one of nature's
best sources and also contain calcium
and vitamin d
and i love the pairing of the wheat
thins with the oysters for some carbs
and fiber
so good sometimes i love sea salt and
vinegar chips like
i have to have sea salt and vinegar
chips in my house
but i'm a weirdo because i only like to
eat them when they're folded
so like when you get a chip that looks
more like a taco
yes that's that's me interesting ritual
but it does kind of make sense i mean
if we're thinking about the sensory
experience of eating
chips the folded ones are more crispy
and i guess there's just like more
texture to interact with
so it makes sense i mean now if she was
feeling
like a more substantial snack maybe
pairing the chips with like a higher
protein dip would be a good idea
but also who the hell does that girl
you just straight up eight protein
packed sardines so
i'ma let you eat your dang chips now
let's see what else she has for lunch
the thing that i eat a lot of the time
during lunch time is
a poke bowl and i'll get a scoop of
salmon a scoop of
spicy tuna spicy mayo tuna on it with
edamame
and furukaki and over a bed of
a salad and a bed of rice tons and tons
of seaweed salad
that sounds incredible um we've got
lots of protein and healthy fats in the
tuna and salmon
plus the fiber and carbs from the salad
and rice
i mean this isn't like a low calorie or
low carb meal
but it's inherently nutrient dense and
really well balanced and most
importantly it sounds like it's
something that she
truly enjoys and in my experience
reviewing these harper's bizarre videos
that is sadly a beautiful magical thing
i love that for lunch because i feel
like it really fills me up without
making me feel um like sleepy yeah
like that makes sense to me and that's
because of the balance inherently
built into these bowls i know we often
think about carbohydrates as being
energizing and they are but research
suggests that
straight up sugar can actually reduce
activity in
unique cells called orexin cells which
contributes to exhaustion and fatigue
but if we pair those carbohydrates with
a source of protein
we get more stable energy and levels of
alertness
this also makes sense from a typical
blood sugar regulation standpoint
because having a meal that is balanced
in carbohydrates
protein and fat will allow the
carbohydrates to be digested and
absorbed
more slowly so you can enjoy their
energizing benefits longer throughout
the day
if i'm trying to be a healthy person
which is not often
i will eat a salad for lunch but mind
you that salad
will have like a ton of cheese on it and
it's probably something pretty crispy
like a crouton
like 75 crouton 25
salad so this is kind of why i typically
avoid calling meals or foods out as
being
healthy because we tend to associate the
healthy food with like a lack of
pleasure or enjoyment
which can result in us trying to kind of
mask or cover up the offending
healthy ingredients i mean tell a child
that broccoli is good for them
it's probably gonna be a hard sell but
tell
child that it's crunchy and green like
their favorite dinosaur
and looks like a baby tree and suddenly
like they're double fisting the stuff
unbelievably
adults are not that different now in all
honesty it does sound like lana is kind
of joking about the 75
crouton to salad ratio but as a general
observation
the poke meal which she described with
so much pleasure and gusto was
naturally produce packed and satisfying
there wasn't an underlying narrative of
the meal needing to be
healthy it just kinda naturally
was but it was also something that she
clearly craved and
really loved so then why can't salad be
the same
why not pack it full of flavorful
colorful ingredients that you love
like roasted sweet beets and tangy goats
cheese
crunchy fennel juicy oranges
my mouth is watering this is just what
sounds really good to me right now
but make a list of your favorite
colorful foods
and you do you so i would say it's best
not to think about needing to eat
healthy
when it's going to impair your enjoyment
of that meal
as this typically does lead us on like a
hunt
for the foods that we actually want to
eat and in the process
we tend to overeat so just make the damn
salad taste good right at the gates
and call it what it is not healthy
not guilt-free not rabbit food just a
big ass bowl
of ingredients that you actually want to
eat
i'll have like iced green tea with lunch
to kind of keep my energy up through the
day
okay cool awesome lots of antioxidants
there so
definitely always a nutritious beverage
choice
so for dinner i without a doubt
will eat noodles if i'm not
on a diet for my job or for anything
for dinner some my like go to is i'll
make
spaghetti and homemade marinara sauce i
will
fry up some really amazing italian
chicken sausages extra extra virgin very
stinky olive oil over my pasta
and then put some pecorino romano cheese
on it i like the stinkier cheese
if i'm not doing that i'll do like a
bowl of ramen
udon with fish cakes and shrimp tempura
chow mein
you know oh i have a great fusilli olive
vodka
and it always goes with a glass of wine
like a sauvignon blanc like a like a
white if i'm feeling feisty
i'll have a glass of a really nice red
wine
wow wow wow wow i am suddenly
super hungry and could totally go for a
bowl of
slurpee nudes right now so
i love how lana doesn't discriminate
between all the different varieties of
noodles
like she's got fusilli to udon chow mein
ramen spaghetti i mean she's given some
love to noodles from literally around
the world
so i first need to just say that i'm
always thrilled to see someone in the
media
not demonizing carbs yes now she did
make a comment that she eats noodles
every day when she's not on a diet
and i do get that sometimes changing
your body may
just kind of be part and parcel of the
job
that show business as messed up as it is
and if changing your body helps you
settle into a character and land the
role and it doesn't interfere with your
long-term relationship with food
cool amazing i mean you do you
but for the average person i do believe
that if something is
such a staple in your life and your diet
you should not attempt to cut it out in
the name of weight loss
that is just asking for a food obsession
or a binge
what i would suggest instead is enjoying
your favorite noodle in moderation
and then bulking it up with the fiber
and nutrients
found in extra veggies and also a source
of protein
so zucchini noodles spaghetti squash
butternut squash noodles or even
shredded cabbage
can all stand beside the real deal in
addition to having of course a source of
protein in there
to help bump up the satiety factor of
your nudes
gotta love them nudes baby
after dinner when i've gotten all ready
for bed
and i'm laying in bed typically a bag
of sea salt and vinegar chips the kettle
sea salt and vinegar chips
i just i have them up ready i also have
seaweed at the ready
at all times that's another snack that i
just do all day long okay
so this girl likes her salty crispy
snacks
and well yeah obviously chips are a fun
sometimes food which we've already
discussed
those little seaweed snacks are actually
also a really great way to get your
crunchy
fix there's admittedly not a whole lot
in them nutrient-wise like no protein or
fiber
and they're pretty low in fat as well
but they
are a lower sodium chip option with no
saturated fat so if you want to satisfy
your crispy
chip mouth hunger you could totally do a
modest portion of the chips supplemented
by a portion of
crispy seaweed snacks that
that would be a pretty cool fun bedtime
snack
all right so what can we say about our
girl lana
honestly it seems to me that lana is a
natural-born intuitive eater
she seems to eat what she likes she eats
enough to satisfy her hunger
and she doesn't have insecurity around
her appetite
for a woman in hollywood perpetually
engrossed in diet culture
i'm sure that that is no easy feat
it sounds like there are still times
that she does need to diet which
i mean probably just comes with the
territory
i think it probably sucks to have to try
to manipulate your body for a job
but that may be a sacrifice actors make
for their craft i
thankfully cannot relate but i also
assume
a lot of actors just see this as like a
job requirement
not unlike you know like a course or a
skill or certification that you need
so it sounds like thankfully those work
diets are not interfering with lana's
relationship with food and love of food
and to that i gotta give the girl props
her diet is also
generally really well balanced with a
very broad variety of nutritious
proteins
healthy fats energizing carbs and lots
of fiber rich fruits and veg
not to mention she prefaced this
interview with the reminder that
she never eats the same thing twice so
that alone is really great evidence of
the variety in her diet
and also any celebrity who talks about
their body being stuffed full of noodles
is pretty damn cool in my books
so on that note that is all that i have
for you guys today
if you like this video please give it a
thumbs up
leave me a comment below if you have
someone else that you want me to review
subscribe to the channel and i will see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye
[Music]